haltung damit ist dieser vorschlag ist
ja vielen dank claudia davis und
herzlich willkommen zurück leif hier im
plenarsaal des deutschen bundestages
es ist in der zwischenzeit sind sie
haben hier nichts verpasst abgestimmt
worden und wir sind pünktlich zurück
nämlich zur aktuellen stunde beantragt
von der cdu csu fraktion zur lage der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge seit beginn des
russischen angriff auf die ukraine sind
laut bundesinnenministerium rund 1000 5
und 7 175.000 menschen
ich gehe aus der ukraine geflohen sind
das nach deutschland gekommen und hier
registriert worden die zahl liegt
wahrscheinlich deutlich höher denn im
regelfall findet ihr an der grenze keine
festen grenzen statt also es geht um die
lage der flüchtlinge um die versorgung
um die unterbringung und die
registrierung wir hören erste rednerin
andrea lindholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen in der ukraine
mitten in europa herrscht krieg putins
pumpen haben die größte flüchtlingskrise
in europa seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
ausgelöst über drei millionen menschen
befinden sich bereits aus der ukraine
auf der flucht heute morgen hat uns der
ukrainische präsident
zugeschaltet aus dem kriegsgebiet noch
einmal eindringlich gebeten auf allen
ebenen zu helfen am sonntag konnte ich
mit mir konnte ich mir mit kollegen an
der polnisch ukrainischen grenze selbst
ein bild von der note machen und es hat
mich zutiefst
erschüttert es waren so viele
vor allem frauen kinder
jugendliche alte frauen die schutz
suchen in polen in deutschland in europa
ihre männer und ihre söhne bleiben
zurück in der heimat
um mit ihrem leben die heimat zu
verteidigen
die erschöpfung die verzweiflung den mut
der frauen zu sehen die vielen kinder
das kann ich auch heute noch kaum in
worte fassen es hat mich sehr berührt
und für uns für die union und für mich
selbst ist vollkommen klar wir müssen
wir müssen mit aller kraft helfen
in der dunkelheit gibt es immer auch
helle hoffnungsschimmer und was wir auch
erlebt haben ist die große
hilfsbereitschaft und die professionelle
organisation unserer polnischen nachbarn
sie haben bereits über 1,5 millionen
menschen aufgenommen polen hat ein
großes herz und einen kühlen kopf und
auch bei uns hier in deutschland haben
die menschen ein großes herz zur
wahrheit gehört aber auch ohne die
vielen ehrenamtlichen helfer und
engagierten kommunalpolitiker
wäre unser staat aufgeschmissen wir
sollten ihnen allen heute ausdrücklich
danken und ihnen versichern dass das
engagement des bundes sie nachhaltig
unterstützen muss und dass wir auch
dafür sorge tragen müssen dass unser
ehrenamt nicht überfordert wird
um hilfe zu ermöglichen braucht es auch
staatliche ordnung und kontrolle und das
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist der
kühle kopf die bundesregierung hat eine
schutzpflicht den vielen frauen kindern
und jugendlichen die aus dem krieg
fliehen die schutz suchen und diese
schutzpflicht hat sie bis jetzt nicht
ausreichend erfüllt weil der
registrierung bei der ankunft an den
bahnhöfen bei der erstaufnahme unter und
der unterbringung herrscht teilweise
chaos und damit nicht genug seit wochen
warnen die polizeigewerkschaften vor
skrupellosen kriminellen die versuchen
frauen und mädchen aus der ukraine in
ihre gewalt zu bekommen nur wenige
hundert meter von hier entfernt
am berliner hauptbahnhof gibt es diese
übergriffe die bundespolizei warnt dort
auf schildern junge frauen und
unbegleitete minderjährige vor
auffälligen
übernachtungsangeboten die warnungen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die sind
richtig aber das darf nicht alles sein
frauen kinder jugendliche die vor krieg
fliehen sie brauchen kein laisser-faire
sie brauchen schutz und ordnende
staatliche strukturen und wenn auch nur
eine ukrainische frau die jetzt bei uns
schutz sucht in der zwangsprostitution
landet oder auch nur ein unbegleiteter
minderjähriger in not gerät weil unser
staat schlecht organisiert ist oder weil
er zu langsam agiert dann lässt sich das
mit nichts wiedergutmachen und
deshalb fordern wir eine sofortige
straffung für frauen und für kinder
zieht die zu uns kommen das bedeutet
eine systematische registrierung direkt
nach der einreise damit wir wissen wer
zu uns kommt wer bleiben wird und um wen
wir uns kümmern müssen darauf zu hoffen
dass die frauen selbst den weg zu einer
aufnahmeeinrichtung oder der
ausländerbehörde finden das ist kein
konzept es braucht schutzzonen an
bahnhöfen in denen professionelle
hilfsorganisationen die frauen und
kinder in empfang nehmen sie versorgen
und in zentral geschützte
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung weiterleiten es
ist kein zustand dass sich irgendwer am
berliner hauptbahnhof und an anderen
bahnhöfen befindet und die frauen
mitnehmen kann und
und es braucht ein krisenstab in dem
bund länder und kommunen dauerhaft oder
verteilung versorgung und alle weiteren
fragen sich austauschen frau ministerin
feser hat diesen krisenstab die grünen
haben einen krisengipfel gefordert ein
flüchtlings gipfel gefordert dieser
woche in der regierungsbefragung vom
tisch gefegt das bräuchte es nicht aber
ich glaube auch die grünen haben zweifel
am krisenmanagement sonst hätten sie
diesen flüchtlings gipfel nicht
gefordert und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der ampel sie sind in der
regierung handeln sie auch danach frau
feser liebe bundesregierung
realisieren nicht den ernst der lage
übernehmen sie verantwortung und
schützen sie die frauen und kinder denn
es werden noch viele verbot vor putins
bomben fliehen
andreas scholz war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion eröffnete hier diese
aktuelle stunde die ihre fraktion
beantragt hat und wäre der bundestag
hier debattiert sitzen ja auch bund und
länder vertreter zusammen auch unter
anderem um darüber zu sprechen die man
die menschen die aus der ukraine
geflüchtet sind am besten versorgt und
unterbringen kann und es gibt eine erste
beschlussvorlage die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit dem
boden läuft allerdings noch daraus geht
zumindest hervor dass bund und länder
die registrierung der ukrainische
kriegswichtige beschleunigen wollen
jetzt die beauftragte der
bundesregierung für antirassismus alaba
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich habe größten respekt vor der ukraine
vor ihrem präsidenten und den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
sie kämpfen in diesen wochen für ihr
land und ihre demokratie sie kämpfen für
werte die auf unsere sind es sind
universelle werte es geht um freiheit
frieden und das leben putins krieg ist
damit ein angriff auf uns alle auf
unsere werte wir unterstützen die
ukraine mit aller kraft
in diesen wochen wir uns oft die worte
putins krieg millionenfaches unsägliches
leid verursacht weil geburtskliniken und
wohnungen zerbombt werden weil frauen
männer und kinder sterben und mir stockt
der atem wenn ich präsident selensky im
bundestag höre wenn ich den mut der
ukrainerin ob ukrainer sehe wenn ich bei
mir zu hause in schwerin in einer
notunterkunft eine frau aus prag tief
wenn sie mir ihr schicksal erzählt ihre
fluchtgeschichte auch wenn die worte
fehlen wir sind nicht sprachlos wir
packen an gemeinsam im schulterschluss
von bund ländern und kommunen gemeinsam
im haupt- und ehrenamt was sind diese
tagen geleistet wird es herausragen
deutschland hilft menschen in größter
not dafür danke ich allen die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
kommunalen verwaltungen dem thw der
bundeswehr den polizeien von bund und
ländern und ich danke ganz besonders den
vielen ehrenamtlichen helferinnen und
helfern deutschland stets zusammen die
menschen
einfach los tagein tagaus dafür gewillt
ihn größter respekt und anerkennung
stand heute sind rund 200.000 menschen
aus der ukraine zu uns geflogen das ist
die größenordnung der hansestadt rostock
und das sind nur die registrierten
tatsächlich sind es weitaus mehr privat
eingereist und untergekommen bei
verwandten und freunden
weil ukrainerinnen und ukrainer ohne
visum einreisen sondern weil wir
niemanden an den grenzen aufhalten der
vorbau und granatsplitter und das ist
auch gut so liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
es ist in dieser schlimmen zeit
ermutigen dass europa zusammen stehen
putins krieg ist ein wendepunkt in der
geschichte europas auch für ein europa
entstanden nach dem horror des zweiten
weltkrieges das jetzt wieder stärker
zusammenwächst die idee des gemeinsamen
europas hat sich nicht erledigt ganz im
gegenteil sie ist aktueller denn je ja
die herausforderung bei der aufnahme und
unterbringung ist jetzt riesengroß in
europa aber auch bei uns in deutschland
darum ist es gut dass wir auf allen
ebenen im regelmäßigen austausch sind
bund länder und kommunen die
koordinierung da können sie sich sicher
sein läuft auf hochtouren in diesen
stunden gerade jetzt spricht der
bundeskanzler aber auch die bundes mit
innenministerin mit allen 16
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der bund koordiniert
die ankünfte von zügen zügen und bussen
ins bundesgebiet die länder melden ihre
kapazitäten zur unterbringung alleine
heute starten zum beispiel
147 brüssel um 9500 plätze mit 909 1500
plätzen die ins gesamte bundesgebiet
fahren in acht bundesländern um berlin
cottbus und hannover zu entlasten das
bamf ist in allen bundesländern mit
hilfe aktiv vor allem bei der
registrierung ebenso helfen bundeswehr
und thw und wir unterstützen bei der
verteilung in deutschland und in der eu
das zeigt die länder und kommunen können
sich auf dem bund verlassen wir
unterstützen denn natürlich wissen wir
alle weder berlin brandenburg oder
bayern können das alleine stemmen ganz
deutschland zieht mit die solidarität
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist in
diesen tagen überwältigend wo melde ich
das jetzt immer gefragt werde
ja ich bin zuversichtlich und ich weiß
aus meiner erfahrung aus meiner arbeit
in der erstaufnahme dass wir 2022 besser
vorbereitet sind als 2015 wir haben in
der eu mit einem historischen
schulterschluss für schnelle und
unbürokratische aufnahme gesorgt wir
ermöglichen sicheren langfristigen
aufenthalt für alle die aus der ukraine
fliehen dafür hat die bundesregierung
mit dem paragraphen 24 aufenthaltsgesetz
gesorgt damit steht auch der zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt offen der zugang zu
integrationskursen
dass es ein kraftakt das ist integration
von anfang an
zum schluss wir müssen jetzt auch klare
haltung zeigen es gibt keine
geflüchteten erster oder zweiter klasse
es darf niemals um herkunft oder
hautfarbe gehen wir lassen nicht zu wenn
drittstaatsangehörige aus der ukraine
einen grenzen diskriminiert werden polen
rumänien und die slowakei haben
klargestellt dass sie das auch nicht
dulden ich nehme solche meldungen von
den die eu aus
seien wir also gemeinsam weiterhin sehr
wasser und wir vergessen die
geflüchteten natürlich nicht die bereits
bei uns sind und schutz suchen ob schon
vorher auch aus der ukraine aus syrien
afghanistan eritrea oder dem irak wir
unterteilen nicht in gruppen wir geben
allen menschen sicherheit die schutz
brauchen weil sie menschen sind
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
nein wir sind in diesen tagen nicht
sprachlos beginnt klare antworten auf
putins angriffskrieg in europa in bund
ländern und kommunen gemeinsam stark
fest an der seite der ukraine vielen
dank
[Applaus]
der nächste redner in dieser debatte in
dieser aktuellen stunde zur lage der
ukrainischen flüchtlinge kommt aus der
fdp fraktion gottfried curio ist der
innenpolitische sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren ja den wirklich vor krieg
fliehen muss geholfen werden natürlich
auch in deutschland wenn die
anrainerstaaten der ukraine überlastet
sind wir wollen hilfsbedürftige
versorgen aber die kapazitäten wer nimmt
denn jetzt denen die kapazitäten weg
nicht nur die paz losen afrikanischen
austauschstudenten die angeblichen
sondern vor allem die hunderttausenden
altfälle von ausreisepflichtigen
asylbewerber die deutschland seit 20.15
mit angabe falscher fluchtgründe
getäuscht haben die diese regierung aber
wie die folge sich weigert abzuschieben
jetzt brauchen wir aber platz für die
wirklich schutzbedürftig meine damen und
herren
ja und meine damen und herren von der
union ihnen wird jetzt der spiegel
vorgehalten weil die altlasten an
illegaler migration das system
verstopfen uns ein gebot von parteien
die gerne illegal zu legalen machen
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt den
sofortigen stopp aller sachwidrige
ideologie projekte den stopp der
resettlement aktionen von weitläufigen
familiennachzug wir brauchen eine
abschiebung offensive herr lindner wo
bleibt denn ihr abschiebe beauftragt da
diese schaufenster ankündigung fakt ist
hunderttausende ausreisepflicht der
merkel migranten nehmen die plätze der
heute fliegenden frauen und kinder aus
der ukraine hier in den aufnahmen weg
das ist eine schande meine damen und
herren aber die innenministerin will
sogar alle ausdruck einer anreisenden
aufnehmen auch nicht du keiner die gar
nicht in not sind und nach hause können
die 18 jahre alte ukrainerin in
düsseldorf vergewaltigt von einem iraker
und die koreaner die sich ukrainische
pässe verstand verschafft hatten die
geht zurück nach polen in deutschland
ist es ihr zu unsicher das ist aus
deutschland geworden als ich ist eine
schande meine damen herren
woran erkennt man wirkliche flüchtlinge
die sind anders als 2015 meist weiblich
haben ihren pass dabei treten dankbar
auf stadt fordert und sie wollen zurück
in die heimat deshalb braucht es für die
kinder und klinischen sonder unterricht
statt irgendwelcher integration die
hilfsbereiten bürger aber ärgert die
kontroll verweigerung der wieder bewusst
zugelassener missbrauch der deutschen
hilfsbereitschaft hier in berlin
ankommende züge werden überhaupt nicht
kontrolliert keine
sicherheitsüberprüfung nichts der
vorsitzende der gewerkschaft der
bundespolizei sieht 40 prozent der
ankommenden insgesamt unkontrolliert
deutschland bleibt wieder sperrangelweit
offen für alle arten unerwünschter
trittbrettfahrer von
wirtschaftsmigranten bis terroristen
denken sie an der von der ukraine jetzt
in der ukraine angeforderten syrischen
kämpfer wer täglich 10.000 betten bereit
halten kann der kann auch ordentlich
kontrollieren für die innere sicherheit
wir wollen nicht dass nach höherer und
orts kraft jetzt afrikanischer
austauschstudent zum neuen passepartout
wird wir fordern jeden platz für
ukrainische alte rheinische frauen und
kinder meine damen und herren das elend
der flüchtlinge das beendet man durch
ein ende der kämpfe da ist russland erst
verantwortlich die verursachung
menschlichen leids zu beenden und laut
jerusalem post fordert der israelische
premier bennett sie lenski auf die
russischen angebote anzunehmen und so
den krieg zu beenden
aber wer de facto dazu beiträgt dass der
krieg immer länger und blutiger wird das
sind auch die die immer mehr waffen
hinein liefern und wer außerhalb der
städte die panzer nicht aufhalten kann
und dann einen guerillakrieg in die
städte trägt auch der erzeugt
flüchtlinge selbstverständlich übergibt
man eine stadt und zerstört und ohne
zivile opfer wenn man militärisch
unterlegen ist selbst wenn man im recht
ist oder wollte irgendwer für den
ernstfall den militärischen häuserkampf
in berlin propagieren angesichts der
unterlegenheit preußens gegenüber dem
aggressor napoleon übergab man berlin
selbstverständlich kampflos ohne
sinnlose tote zerstörung oder aufruf zum
volkssturm von 10 die listen gegen eine
armee das vermeidet große flucht
bewegungen und die option der nato
mitgliedschaft für putin kriegsgrund
hatte man mit einem satz von tisch
nehmen können wie mit dem
deutsch-französischen veto von 2008 wer
wagt es den menschen zu sagen dass ihr
leben und die unversehrtheit ihrer
heimat weniger wert sind als die option
auf brüssel die verbindung mit der nato
es gilt doch fluchtbewegungen immer im
ansatz zu vermeiden sie lenski und polen
wollen die kriegsbeteiligung in den
westen tragen frau ersten will
nato-soldaten in der ukraine nicht
ausschließen friedrich merz kann sich
nato entscheidungen vorstellen und putin
zu stoppen solche kriegs ausweitung ist
gefährliche zündelei das brauchen wir
nicht schon gar nicht im deutschen namen
lassen sie uns lieber anschließend an
große traditionen deutscher entspannungs
und verständigung spolien damen und
herren und eines sollte klar sein sobald
die kämpfe vorbei sind unterstützen wir
die menschen auf ihrem weg zurück in die
heimat beim wiederaufbau das ist dann
nicht die ideologie der globalisten die
menschen über den globus schieben wollen
sondern das ist das wirkliche interesse
der geflüchteten es sind menschen die
ihre heimat lieben die ihre heimat
bewahren wollen sie haben unser
mitgefühl sie haben unsere hilfe
die rede des innenpolitischen sprechers
der fdp-fraktion gottfried curio hier
zur lage der ukrainischen
geflüchteten laut bundesinnenministerium
hat deutschland bislang
187.000 ukrainische geflüchtete
aufgenommen allerdings werden nicht alle
geflüchtete auch erfasst denn natürlich
nur die die von der bundespolizei auch
festgestellt werden die zahlen dürften
also deutlich höher liegen so schätzt
man filiz polat spricht jetzt für die
grünen sie
wir erleben
deutschland und europa stehen vor der
größten fluchtbewegung seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg und
deutschland hat mit dieser
bundesregierung gezeigt dass es jetzt
darauf ankommt
und mehr denn je als in der
vergangenheit die geflüchteten in den
mittelpunkt zu stellen und nicht sich
über zahlen und obergrenzen zu
zerstreiten und ich glaube unsere
koalition kann froh sein dass sie mit
ministerin nancy faeser jemanden in
brüssel hatte der es geschafft die es
geschafft hat europa zu einen und in
kürzester zeit nach 20 jahren erstmalig
die richtlinie zum vorübergehenden
schutz zu aktivieren das war wichtig und
gut so angesichts der wachsenden zahlen
meine damen und herren
und frau staatsministerin rima badeen
radio waren sie haben es gesagt mit
dieser richtlinie mit der aktivierung
dieser richtlinie sind genau die dinge
jetzt möglich die menschen haben zugang
zur gesundheitsversorgung die menschen
bekommen den zugang zum arbeitsmarkt und
sie bekommen unbürokratisch zugang zu
den integrationskursen
hätten wir diese richtlinie schon 2015
und 16 aktivieren können hätten wir uns
einiges erspart was wir erleben mussten
vor allem die menschen die aus syrien
geflohen sind meine damen und herren
für uns gewinnen ist 90 die grünen ist
es jetzt wichtig dass den worten taten
folgen was heißt das leider und das muss
ich so sagen ist in unserem
aufenthaltsgesetz nach der aktivierung
der richtlinie die rechtsgrundlage der
paragraf 24 ding ja alle mittlerweile
kennen und im gesetzestext heißt es
leider eben nicht dass sie
uneingeschränkt den zugang zum
gesundheitssystem haben oder dass sie
arbeitsmarkt berechtigt sind
nichtsdestotrotz hat ministerin nancy
faeser über den verordnungswege ist
versucht möglich zu machen aber wir sind
uns nicht sicher herr staatsminister
staatssekretär ob wir eine
bundeseinheitliche umsetzung hinbekommen
denn wir wissen in deutschland und in
den bundesländern regieren
unterschiedliche farbkonstellationen
und wenn wir eines wollen dann ist es
dass alle geflüchtete gleich behandelt
werden die aus der ukraine fliehen und
alle wie ich eingangs gesagt hat habe
unbürokratisch zugang zur
versorgungsleistung und zu den
integrationsmaßnahmen bekommen frau
staatsministerin von anfang an
und deshalb wollen wir sicherstellen
dass
die menschen anspruchsberechtigte werden
auf einen integrationskurs und nicht nur
im zulassungs wege und damit abhängig
sind von kapazitäten wir wollen dass sie
erwerbs die erwerbs erlaubnis erhalten
ohne wenn und aber und das unabhängig
davon ob sie drittstaatsangehörige sind
aus der ukraine oder ukrainische
staatsbürgerin meine damen und herren
das zweite thema ist die registrierungs
frage das bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge ist angehalten nach der
aktivierung der richtlinie ein
register aufzusetzen und dieses register
wird jetzt erarbeitet das wurde im
innenausschuss auch so vorgetragen es
werden viele viele mitarbeiterinnen
eingesetzt um so schnell wie möglich die
menschen so registrieren für uns ist es
aber wichtig das haben wir auch deutlich
gemacht dass die registrierung schon an
den knotenpunkten erfolgt denn das was
wir erleben joachim stamp sitzt ja auch
hier dass die geflüchteten die sozusagen
keine familiären bezüge haben klar
wissen müssen in welches bundesland zu
kommen und die bundesländer müssen klar
wissen in welche kommunen sie verteilen
und das geht nur mit der registrierung
an den knotenpunkten nicht erst in den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen und damit
werden wir dann auch der gewachsenen und
zunehmend dynamischen entwicklung der
fluchtbewegung gerecht meine damen und
herren
und in diesem sinne bei unsere forderung
frau lindholz ein flüchtlings gipfel zu
fordern weil nämlich wir nicht
ignorieren dass in allen
landesparlamenten genau diese diskussion
stattfindet der städtetag und der
landkreistag an uns diese frage
adressiert hat und wir werden uns sicher
sein dass heute auch nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
bundeskanzler olaf scholz ein schritt
auf uns zugeht und diesen flüchtlings
gipfel einberuft meine damen und herren
und letzter satz ich möchte joachim
stamm zitieren mit dem ich in den
koalitionsverhandlungen die basis
gemeinsam mit stefan thomé und auch
nancy faeser legen durfte für diese
fortschritts koalition in der
neuausrichtung der migrations und
flüchtlingspolitik die joachim deswegen
ist es unsere aufgabe so hast du es
gesagt in der sondersitzung des
nordrhein westfälischen
landtages dass wir diesen diktator mit
aufnahmebereitschaft und vor allem mit
mitmenschlichkeit entgegentreten und
dass wir alles dafür tun uns nicht
spalten zu lassen herzlichen dank für
eure aufmerksamkeit
soweit filiz polat hier für die grünen
hat ja auch noch mal die forderung
wiederholt dass es einen flüchtlings
gipfel geben soll auch das hat er ja der
deutsche städtetag gefordert klarer
bürger spricht jetzt für die allen
linksfraktion sie ist sprecherin für
flucht politik
präsidentin die wir kolleginnen und
kollegen der demokratischen fraktionen
seit beginn der russischen angriffe auf
die ukraine am 24 februar sind nach
angaben der vereinten nationen mehr als
drei millionen menschen aus der ukraine
geflohen die meisten von ihnen ins
nachbarland polen in deutschland wurden
bisher über
175.000 geflüchtete aus der ukraine
registriert mit zehntausenden mehr ist
zu rechnen die schutzsuchenden menschen
werden in der eu mit einer riesigen
hilfsbereitschaft und solidarität
aufgenommen sie bekommen unkompliziert
einen schutzstatus können hier arbeiten
und durften bei verwandten und bekannten
unterkommen soweit dies möglich war das
ist sehr gut dass die bundesregierung
aber auch die eu ebene hier schnell
gehandelt hat dass dafür ein dankeschön
von unserer seite aber all das zeigt
auch wie eine solidarische
flüchtlingspolitik funktionieren kann
wenn der politische wille da ist
die aufnahme derer die vor krieg gewalt
und zerstörung fliehen wäre nicht
möglich ohne das beeindruckende
engagement vieler menschen die auf
freiwilliger basis den ankommenden
unterstützen und für unterkünfte und
verpflegung sorgen vielen dank an dieser
stelle an alle ehren amtlichen die hier
großartiges geleistet haben und immer
noch leisten
doch dieses ehrenamtliche engagement
kann nicht nur ob kann nicht auf dauer
staatliche strukturen ersetzen in vielen
städten und gemeinden fehlt es aktuell
an qualifiziertem personal an wohnungen
und weiteren ressourcen ich war letzte
woche selbst am berliner hauptbahnhof
und habe als freiwilliger im infodesk
unterstützt jeden tag kommen dort
tausende menschen an tendenz steigend
und die unterkünfte sind so voll dass
die menschen teilweise in zügen und
bussen übernachten müssen deshalb ist es
aus unserer sicht richtig dass jetzt
geflüchtete auch auf andere bundesländer
verteilt werden es geht aber nicht nur
um verpflegung und unterbringung sondern
auch um qualifizierte beratung ich nenne
ihnen mal ein beispiel als ich letzte
woche am hauptbahnhof war berichtete mir
eine person dass sie ihren vater der aus
der ukraine geflogen war aus polen
abholen wolle der vater sei allerdings
dement und im gleiten seiner pflegerin
vor dem krieg geflüchtet die frage war
kann diese pflegerin die keine
ukrainische staatsbürgerschaft hat
ebenfalls nach deutschland kommt bekommt
sie hier auch schutz das ist nur ein
beispiel von vielen und es zeigt dass es
mehr professionelle anlaufstellen für
flüchteten braucht das ist eine
staatliche aufgabe hier muss schnell
gehandelt werden die bundesregierung
muss länder und kommunen hier finanziell
unterstützen bei all der berechtigten
freude über das solidarische über die
solidarische aufnahme der geflüchteten
aus der ukraine dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dass die abschottung an der
eu-außengrenze gegenüber menschen
unverändert weiter geht polen ist immer
noch dabei eine fast sechs meter hohe
mauer zur abwehr von nichteuropäischen
geflüchteten zu bauen polnische
sicherheitskräfte schicken immer noch
schutzsuchende rechtswidrig in die kälte
oder gar in den tod zurück oder sperren
sie geschlossene lager nach wie vor
werden schutzsuchende unter unwürdigen
bedingungen in hot spot lagern in den
griechischen inseln festgehalten und
nach wie vor ertrinken menschen im
mittelmeer oder werden an den eu
außengrenzen mit brutaler wald gewalt an
der einreise in die eu gehindert und
zurückgewiesen das ist nicht nur ganz
klar rechtswidrig weil das reglement
verbot eben eine absolute und notstands
feste garantie ist ist zeigt auch eine
doppelmoral im umgang mit geflüchteten
die aus meiner sicht ausdruck eines tief
sitzenden rassismus ist
dabei sollte doch klar sein dass man bei
menschen keinen unterschied macht wenn
sie vor kriegen viel es darf eben keine
geflüchteten erster und zweiter klasse
geben
und auch bei der aufnahme von
geflüchteten aus der ukraine kommt es zu
rassistischer diskriminierung auch wenn
sie als staatsministerin das verurteilen
was ich natürlich sehr begrüßen sieht
die realität leider anders aus
es kommt zu diskriminierung von menschen
die aus der ukraine fliehen zu
rassistischer diskriminierung
studierende aus afrikanischen ländern
werden an den grenzen auszügen geholt
durchsucht und schikaniert im
unterschied zur ukrainischen
staatsangehörigen haben sie zudem in der
regel keinen anspruch auf einen
unkomplizierten schutzstatus die frau
kollegin pollert hat es angekündigt
diese schutzlücken müssen aus meiner
sicht noch geschlossen werden
studierende aus drittstaaten müssen die
möglichkeit bekommen hier ihr studium
fortzusetzen wenn sie das möchten und
nun zum schluss noch ein wort zur union
frau lindholz ehrlich gesagt finde ich
unerträglich dass sie in dieser
notsituation in der ausnahmsweise vieles
von der bundesregierung richtig gemacht
wird diesen wieder dabei reden und
versuchen ängste zu schüren ich habe
ende gleich meine vorrede ja dass wir
hier solche schlimmen vorgehen und wie
ihre politischen zwecke verwenden ist
einfach 30 wenn sie es wirklich ernst
meinen würden dann würden wir das
problem unter einer anderen überschrift
nämlich ein welche nachtflüge
diskutieren ein glück dass sie nicht
mehr in der wie die rockigen
[Applaus]
dr stefan thomé spricht jetzt für die
fdp fraktion
stefan thomé sitz im ausschuss für
inneres und heimat
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen die rede des
ukrainischen präsidenten wladimir lenski
heute morgen hier im deutschen bundestag
hat mich sicherlich uns alle extrem
aufgewühlt die von ihm beschworenen
bilder von städten wie dem erdboden
gleichgemacht werden von krankenhäusern
schulen wohnhäusern die beschossen
werden tausende unschuldige ukraine die
gestorben sind all das ist nicht zu
ertragen und schon leute heute lässt
sich vorhersagen wo der platz wladimir
putins in der geschichte zu suchen sein
wird in der ahnengalerie der großen
menschheitsverbrechen damen und herren
selensky hat von den mauern gesprochen
hinter denen wir uns nicht verschanzen
dürfen niemand weiß so genau wie wir
deutsche bauern sind unmenschlich uk
darf nicht hinter einer mauer
verschwinden meine damen und herren
innerhalb der letzten drei wochen habe
bereits mehr als drei millionen menschen
vor allem frauen und kinder die ukraine
verlassen nur zum vergleich in den
flüchtlingslagern 2015 und 16 sind in
diesen zwei jahren ungefähr 1,2
millionen asylanträge in deutschland
gestellt worden nach polen kam innerhalb
dreier wochen heute schon fast zwei
millionen menschen das zeigt uns wir
erleben die größte fluchtbewegung die
europa seit dem zweiten weltkrieg erlebt
hat und vielleicht machen wir noch gar
keine vorstellung welche dimensionen
diese flucht noch annehmen
deshalb danken wir den vielen
ehrenamtlichen helfern die ihre freie
zeit oder ein freies zimmer den
ankommenden widmen oder für den
täglichen bedarf einkaufen all diese
menschen verdienen dank und respekt oder
ich will weil ich dafür beispiele kenne
auch ausdrückliche reden dass ich den
freiwilligen helfern auch menschen mit
russischer herkunft wir finden die
voller scham für die kriegsverbrechen
sind die in diesen tagen in russischen
namen begangen werden und jetzt großen
anfeindungen in deutschland ausgesetzt
sind wir dürfen auch nicht wir dürfen
auch nicht putin gleichsetzen mit
russland oder pute gleichsetzen mit
allen menschen russisch sprechen oder
russischstämmige sind zwei damen und
herren aber
natürlich stößt auf freiwilligkeit
irgendwo an ihre grenzen das gilt sowohl
im privaten wie auch im öffentlichen
bereich und deswegen dürfen es auch
nicht allein nur auf freiwilligkeit
verlassen wir sind voller anerkennung
für die vielen freiwilligen helfer und
ehrenamtler aber der rechtsstaat hat
auch eindeutige regeln wer welchen
beitrag leisten muss und folglich werden
wir diese regeln auch anwenden deswegen
hat die bundesregierung gestern die
verteilung auf die final verteilung der
flüchtlinge nach dem königsteiner
schlüssel auf die bundesländer aktiviert
und das ist richtig so aber auch in der
eu müssen wir klare regeln definieren
die wir als rechts- und
wertegemeinschaft unseren humanitären
verpflichtungen jungen gerecht werden
wollen und wer welchen beitrag erbringen
erbringen muss denn auch humanitär
pflichten sind pflichten meine damen und
herren und deshalb begrüße ich dass die
bundesregierung darauf hinwirken wird
das ein fairer europäische
verteilungsschlüssel angewandt wird so
dass ich nicht einige wenige hinter der
hilfsbereitschaft der vielen wegducken
können und wir die fehler der jahre 2015
16 nicht wiederholen
eine gerechte verteilung setzt natürlich
auch voraus dass wir wissen wer bei uns
ankommt und deswegen müssen wir die
menschen die hier ankommen auch erfassen
und registrieren denn nur wenn wir
wissen wie viele menschen ankommen wer
ankommt wer davon alte menschen sind
kinder familien oder alleinstehende nur
dann können wir die hilfen auch
zielgerichtet an den mann und an die
frau und an das kind bringen kinder die
zum als kriegshandlung miterleben
mussten sind traumatisiert müssen
betreut werden älter menschen brauchen
pflege und betreuung und deshalb hat die
bundesregierung auch bereits begonnen
mit der registrierung der flüchtlinge
denn eine möglichst lückenlose
registrierung schützt auch die menschen
wie bei uns ankommen weil damen und
herren und damit all das europaweit
geschehen kann braucht es insgesamt eine
koordinierung durch die europäische
kommission und eine faire verteilung auf
die mitgliedstaaten der eu
meine damen und herren putins krieg gilt
in erster linie der ukraine aber in
zweiter linie soll auch dazu dienen
europa durch eine flüchtlingswelle zu
destabilisieren und indem wir diese
flüchtlingswelle gemeinsam europäisch
meistern durchkreuzen wir den plan des
russischen diktators und setzten gegen
die barbarei ein zeichen der
menschlichkeit wir zeigen dass unser
platz jetzt an die seite der ukrainer
und ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
stephan thomae hat hier auch noch einmal
an die rede des iranischen präsidenten
wolodimir seelands gehe erinnerte heute
morgen hier zugeschaltet war und sich
hier an das parlament
gewendet hat falls sie die rede verpasst
haben finden sie diese natürlich auch
auf unserem phoenix youtube-kanal detlef
seif spricht jetzt für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
präsidentin meine damen und herren
lassen sie mich zunächst vorab deutlich
zum ausdruck bringen dass es völlig
unverständlich ist dass die
bundesinnenministerium heute dieser
aktuellen stunde unentschuldigt
fernbleibt
die regierungsvertreter haben in den
letzten tagen im innenausschuss und bei
der gestrigen
regierungsbefragung
jegliche kritik an der bearbeitung der
vertriebenen krise von sich gewiesen
warum dann aber die hilferufe aus den
bundesländern
und wie kommt die deutsche
polizeigewerkschaft zu dem schluss dass
die bundesregierung noch nicht mal im
ansatz
einen plan hat wie so fordert der
deutsche städte und gemeindebund ein
koordiniertes vorgehen von bund ländern
und kommunen
die chefs der staatskanzleien sehen den
bund hier in der besonderen
verpflichtung die bundesweite
koordinierung schnell zu verbessern
umfangreiche lageberichte technische
unterstützung und vor allem ein
strukturiertes verteilungsverfahren sind
das gebot der stunde
wenn bundesverkehrsminister volker
wissing den ländern die schuld gibt und
sie auffordert frühzeitig in großem
umfang
aufnahmekapazitäten zu melden verkennt
er das hauptproblem wir haben es mit der
größten vertriebenen krise seit ende des
zweiten weltkriegs zu tun dass flucht
geschehen ist sehr dynamisch und niemand
kann die exakte zahl der vertriebenen
vorhersehen die vereinten nationen
rechnen mit bis zu acht millionen
menschen die die ukraine verlassen das
ist aber keine obergrenze
offensichtlich selbst putin seine
kriegsmaschinerie gegen die
zivilbevölkerung auch deshalb ein um
möglichst große flucht bewegung zu
verursachen und wir können auch in
deutschland keine zahlen prognostizieren
und genau hier auf das ist der
knackpunkt muss sich die bundesregierung
einstellen appel nummer eins an die
bundesregierung
verstecken sie sich nicht hinter den
ländern und kommunen
es reicht nicht wenn sie wie bisher auf
die flüchtlingsströme die in deutschland
ankommen reagieren gefragt sind jetzt
führung vorausschau und planung und zwar
eine planung die zu erwartende
flüchtlingszahl berücksichtigt sonst
werden wir vor allem aber die
flüchtlinge um die es geht eine böse
überraschung erleben appell nummer zwei
an die bundesregierung es sollte
schnellstmöglich einen vertriebenen
gipfel statt finde es wirklich
erforderlich und entsprechen sie auch
dem vorschlag der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft eine professionelle
aufbauorganisation muss auf den weg
gebracht werden appel nummer drei an die
bundesregierung tun sie alles um einen
missbrauch des vertriebenen schutzes zu
verhindern im innenausschuss haben sie
zwar erklärt dass sie den kreis der
schutz berechtigten wie er in dem
eu-beschluss aufgeführt ist nicht
erweitern wollen fakt ist aber dass
zunächst alle menschen die die aus der
ukraine kommen nach der rechtsverordnung
des bundesinnenministeriums vom siebten
märz 2022
keinen aufenthaltstitel benötigen keine
unterscheidung nach rechtmäßig
unrechtmäßig keine frage danach ob
strich drittstaatsangehörige zurück in
ihre heimat können gefahrlos
es ist auch unbefriedigend dass aktuell
keine umfassende registrierungen der
personen umgesetzt wird die begründung
der ministerin dass eine rechtsgrundlage
zur registrierung fehlt ist nicht
stichhaltig
ukrainische staatsangehörige können ganz
klar visumsfrei einreisen aber nichts
spricht dagegen dass sie im zuge eines
gesuchs registriert werden wie das
gesetz ist auch vorsieht
und wenn die bundesinnenministerium
betont dass man doch bitte nicht die
menschen an der deutsch polnischen
grenze nochmals stundenlang in der kälte
warten lassen könne ist das richtig aber
bei einer professionellen umsetzung ist
das gar nicht erforderlich machen wir es
wie die polen die die registrierungen an
einen benefit knüpfen nämlich an
bestimmte staatliche leistungen und eine
gute und professionelle regierungsarbeit
fängt nicht erst an der deutschen grenze
an die enge zusammenarbeit mit den
behörden der ukrainischen
anrainerstaaten insbesondere mit polen
ist wichtig meine damen und herren das
schicksal der vom angriffskrieg
russlands betroffenen menschen berührt
uns alle öffnen wir unser hart möglichst
weit und unterstützen die ukraine und
ihre menschen aber bitte vergessen wir
den verstand nicht damit die hilfe
bestmöglich ankommt bei denen die es
benötigen und zwar nur bei denen die
wirklich schutzbedürftig sind vielen
dank
[Applaus]
größter luxus spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion
vielleicht ganz am anfang zu ihnen herr
kollege sei wenn sie eben richtig
zugehört hätten hätten sie mitbekommen
dass die minister dass die ministerin
bei der mpk ist die jetzt gerade in den
minuten zu ende geht und das ist auch
der verschiebung der debatte schuld und
ich würde sie bitten einfach damals ist
sie nach dem teppich zu bleiben
da haben wir haben diese zu legen
hingegen
wenige meter von diesem rednerpult
entfernt kommen tausende menschen an die
vor dem krieg in der ukraine fliehen
müssen als ich in der vergangenen woche
am bahnhof war stand ich mitten unter
ihnen nicht zu übersehen war ihr in
ihrem gesicht stand der schrecken des
krieges
traurige augen verängstigte blicke
kinder die unter schock einfach nur
verstummen mütter die irgendwie
funktionieren im fremden land
herausgerissen aus ihrem familienleben
sie wissen nicht ob sie ihre söhne ihre
brüder ihre männer ihre väter überhaupt
wieder sehen sie wissen nicht ob sie
ihre zurückgebliebene ob sie ihre
zurückgeblieben angehörigen irgendwann
wieder in die arme schließen können
der krieg in der ukraine der krieg in
europa bringt schrecklichen leid für so
viele menschen er ist eine humanitäre
katastrophe für die es nur einen
schuldigen gibt präsident putin
seit beginn seines angriffskrieges sind
schon drei millionen menschen geflüchtet
und diese zahl steigt jede minute in dem
dieser krieg tobt sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen die
eindringliche rede des ukrainischen
präsidenten seelands die heute morgen
hat und ich denke uns allen unsere große
verantwortung deutlich gemacht wir
müssen alles tun um diesen krieg zu
beenden
wir müssen alles tun um das leid der
menschen zu lindern ich bin dankbar dass
unsere regierung genau dies mit ihren
unermüdlichen friedensbemühungen
versucht und auch weiter versuchen muss
lassen sie uns dafür jenseits von
parteipolitischen inszenierungen
zusammenstehen und lassen sie uns
gemeinsam zeigen
deutschland steht solidarisch an der
seite der ukraine
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
erleben die größte fluchtbewegung seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg jede minute die
wir hier zusammen sind kommen weitere
menschen schwangere frauen menschen mit
einer behinderung älteren menschen
neugeborene oder unbegleitete
minderjährige
was jetzt zählt ist eine schnelle und
unbürokratische hilfe ich bin froh dass
für diese hilfe gemeinsam im
schulterschluss auch mit unseren
europäischen partnern geben mit der
aktivierung der sogenannten eu
massenzustrom richtlinie bieten dir
unmittelbaren schutz wir gewähren einen
aufenthaltstitel und zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt sowie leistungs
berechtigung nach dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz
kinder können zur schule gehen und
erwachsene haben die möglichkeit an
integrationskursen teilzunehmen
angesichts des riesigen zustroms
unterstützt der bund mit mussten bei der
verteilung der menschen um überlastungen
an knotenpunkten zu verhindern
gleichzeitig helfen die mit arbeiten des
bundesamt für migration flüchtlinge als
register behörde bei der erfassung
gemeinsam mit den ländern und kommunen
organisieren wir so die nötige hilfe
besonders wichtig ist mir die liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen dass wir die
vielen kinder mit ihren schrecklichen
erlebnissen nicht alleingelassen
wir müssen kindern schnell eine
tagesstruktur geben wir müssen die
aufnahme in schulen in gemeinden in
vereinen in den alltag möglichst schnell
unterstützen wir müssen ihre seelischen
wunden heilen und hier für psychosoziale
angebote bereitstellen
schutzlücken dürfen für die besonders
gefährdeten gruppen nicht entstehen die
wir kolleginnen kollegen
gerade bei der unterbringung muster
kinderschutz oberste priorität haben die
bomben des krieges haben den so jungen
menschen nur wenigen sekunden ihre
kindheit genommen wir wollen alles dafür
tun denen diese kindheit hier
zurückzugeben sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen als ich vergangene woche am
bahnhof zwischen all den geflüchteten
menschen stand habe ich mich hilflos und
dankbar zugleich gefühlt hilflosen
angesichts des leidens der menschen und
dankbar in einem land zu leben in dem es
so viel solidarität gibt denn neben all
den
denn neben all dem leid ist es eine
enorme hilfsbereitschaft und solidarität
allgegenwärtig ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei allen bedanken die sich so
engagiert einsetzen
liebe kollegen kollegen jeder mensch der
auf der flucht ist braucht schutz sei es
aus der ukraine aus afghanistan aus
jemen oder aus einem anderen land jeder
der vor krieg und gewalt flüchtenden
mensch muss deshalb gleichermaßen
willkommen sein egal welcher
nationalität er angehört es ist unsere
politische und menschliche aufgabe alles
dafür zu tun um menschen auf der flucht
und in ihren heimatländern zu helfen ich
wünsche mir dass wir hier im parlament
von der großen hilfsbereitschaft der
menschen in unserem land leiten lassen
deutschland ist ein starkes land lassen
sie uns diese stärke nutzen lassen sie
uns parteiübergreifend alles dafür tun
den geflüchteten menschen
bestmöglichen schutz zu geben solange
dies nötig ist herzlichen dank
die unionsfraktion hat diese aktuelle
stunde hier verlangt und deswegen
diskutieren die abgeordneten über die
lage der ukrainischen flüchtlinge und es
ist in diesem krieg so dass besonders
diejenigen die den schutz besonders
brauchen eventuell gefährdet auch sind
schätzungsweise 90 prozent der mehr als
drei millionen menschen die aus der
ukraine gefroren sind sind frauen und
kinder
für die grünen spricht jetzt leeren
eckert
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger wir sehen die
bilder der menschen die gerade zu uns
kommen die frau kollegin hat es gerade
eindrucksvoll beschrieben erschöpft
desorientiert sind verwandte und freunde
zurückgelassen mussten aus ihrem zuhause
entfliehen das sind bilder in denen auch
mir die luft wegbleibt verzweiflung sich
auch auf uns auf mich überträgt
unsicherheit vor dem was kommt aber auch
wut auf den verursacht verursacher all
dieses leid ist
und in dieser emotion das wird
durchbrochen wenn ich sehe dass die
helferinnen ihre einsatzkleidung in
warnwesten die feuerwehrleute das thw
die anderen hilfsorganisationen kommen
und dann wächst meine entschlossenheit
dass wir alles tun diesen menschen zu
helfen und alles dazu tun der ukraine
bei seite zu stehen
jeden tag sind jetzt helfer im land
unterwegs im einsatz packen an da wird
nicht gefragt wer kommt da sondern wann
geht's los bei uns im ort wurde direkt
am nächsten tag schon überlegt welchen
ort wandeln wir um in eine unterkunft
welche touren allen haben wir wie bauen
wir die verpflegung auf und wie schnell
das geht habe ich bei meiner eigenen
feuerwehr erlebt da kam der
einsatzbefehl und plopp plopp plopp
sofort waren die zusagen da wer alles
kommt und wer mit aufbaut da finden
infoabend der stadt von freiwilligen für
freiwilligen denn die helfer kreise sind
ja immer noch aktiv da sagen jetzt die
die seit vielen jahren geflüchtete
betreuen dies geht in zolling zum
beispiel gibt es eine super anleitung
wie werden geflüchtete zu hause
aufgenommen empathisch so aus der
anwender sich dass man weiß die leute
wissen wovon sie reden wie mache ich die
meldung vordruck für die e mail alles da
unglaubliches engagement und ich weiß
dass es überall in unserer republik
menschen gibt die gerade mit aller kraft
dieses engagement auf die straße bringen
dieses engagement von unten das
ehrenamtliche aus den städten und
gemeinden das macht unser land stark und
sie stehen an der ersten stelle um
schutz zu bieten und die menschen
aufzunehmen
eine große aufgabe steht vor uns und
diesen elan dieser menschen die jetzt
gerade agieren den brauchen wir auch
hier wir müssen einfach
merken dazu gehört auch aus der
vergangenheit zu lernen
2015/2016 und das ist leider unter dem
vorherigen bundesinnenminister nicht
passiert mit einer verkraften debatte
verbunden auf was können wir jetzt stolz
sein und aufpassen nicht was haben wir
geschafft und was nicht da haben wir
nicht aus den fehlern gelernt und uns
nicht verbessert
haben wir wirklich die hürden abgebaut
die uns mitgeteilt worden sind sind wir
auch die helferinnen und helfer
eingegangen die ja vor ort selber ihre
abläufe optimiert haben feldbetten
knappheit gibt es schon wieder weil wir
nichts eingelagert haben ich bin der
meinung wir haben zu wenig getan um uns
zu verbessern drei kleine beispiele vor
dem hintergrund 2015 2016 gibt es das
sogenannte labor 5000 eine einheit
schnell aufbau war verlegte an vielen
stellen jetzt im einsatz am flughafen
tegel um leute unterzubringen 5000 stück
einer einheit haben wir eine wird gerade
geschafft wir bräuchten vielmehr in der
aktuellen situation könnte mir so viel
besser damit helfen
zweites beispiel spontan helfer
hochwasser geflüchtete unterbringen
wieder hochwasser die art katastrophe
jedes mal das resümee es gibt spontan
helfer und wir haben nicht die struktur
und zu verknüpfen zu verbinden die
richtig einzusetzen abzulösen und es
kann ja nicht unser anspruch sein dass
wenn die staatliche struktur kommt dass
wir dann schlechter sind als das was
gern amtlich aufgebaut worden ist das
heißt jetzt in die spontan helfer
endlich gehen und lehren ziehen aus 2015
und die auch mitnehmen und umsetzen
und dann das thema anerkennung in jeder
rede wurde den helferinnen und helfern
gedankt und ich weiß dass viele sich
freuen darüber ich weiß aber dass viele
mehr als warme worte brauchen wir haben
in unserem koalitionsvertrag endlich die
helfer gleichstellung dass der
feuerwehrmann genau so behandelt wird
wie die helferin von dak wenn sie eine
nacht helfen und der eine zu hause
bleiben davon der andere nicht so geht
es nicht wir brauchen die helfer
gleichstellung jetzt demnächst
ehrenzeichen für 2015 2016 gibt es immer
noch kein ehrenzeichen auch kleine
sachen wo wir sagen müssen das ist
anerkennung und wertschätzung und in den
letzten jahren gerade bei mir in meinem
wahlkreis weiß ich dass viele helfer
kreise auch gesagt haben wir wurden eher
als klotz am bein wahrgenommen als als
bereicherung das ändert sich jetzt
hoffentlich und das sollten wir dann
auch so in zukunft durchhalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen bürger lassen sie uns das
ehrenamt und unserem bevölkerungsschutz
jetzt gemeinsam stärken und aus diesen
krisen lernen und da geld investieren
für die unterbringung für die
wertschätzung für die helfer
gleichstellung vielen dank
das für die grünen und die bund länder
konferenz von bundeskanzler olaf scholz
und den regierungschefs der 16
bundesländer ist mittlerweile zu ende
gegangen wir erwarten in kürze eine
pressekonferenz des bundeskanzlers wenn
die es werden wir uns dort natürlich
live schalten wir hören jetzt auf eine
weitere stimme aus den ländern joachim
stamm stellvertretende ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen spricht text
damen und herren ich habe das gestern
hier ausgeführt wladimir putin will mit
vertreibung
europa destabilisieren
unsere gesellschaften destabilisieren er
will uns auch spalten
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen auch als
mitglied des bundesrates wo uns das gott
sei dank erspart bleibt im bundesrat
selbst jedenfalls eine solche partei
gibt es eben leider auch in diesem
parlament an eine gruppierung die genau
diesem ziel von putin vorschub leisten
will aber die demokraten in diesem haus
sind stärker und wir werden gemeinsam
die solidarität mit den menschen in der
ukraine
verteidigen
wir üben solidarität mit den
vertriebenen wir sind in einer anderen
situation ich glaube dass das auch
wichtig ist immer wieder zu erklären ist
es eine andere situation als
2015 sie ist aber nicht weniger
herausfordernd
sie ist vielleicht sogar noch
herausfordernder
wir haben eine andere situation heitz
2015 ball momentan in großen mengen
frauen und kinder zu uns kommen und das
ist natürlich besonders herausfordernd
weil wir für die auch in den nächsten
wochen die entsprechenden angebote auch
in der betreuung und vor allem auch in
der bildung schaffen müssen
darauf sind wir ja so nicht vorbereitet
gewesen wir wissen alle um den mangel an
lehrerinnen und lehrern den wir in
deutschland haben wir wissen auch dass
wir nicht ausreichend
schulpsychologinnen und schulpsychologen
haben was die trauma betreuung angeht
das sind alles herausforderungen mit
denen wir zu tun haben haben auch nicht
genügend erzieherinnen und erzieher das
wird für uns alle eine ganz ganz
besondere herausforderung und vollends
hat natürlich recht wenn sie sagt dass
es auch unsere aufgabe ist gerade den
frauen und kindern den unbegleiteten
minderjährigen einen besonderen schutz
zu geben
ich will das aber ganz deutlich sagen
das wird auch deswegen eine besondere
herausforderung weil so viele in so
kurzer zeit jetzt kommen und auch das
ist ein unterschied zu
2015 und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
wirklich alle in dieser debatte
verstanden haben und ich rede nicht nur
von der debatte hier in diesem haus
sondern ich rede auch darüber wie das
thema in europa bisher diskutiert worden
ist wo sich hauptstädte zu wort melden
die sagen ja es ist auch bereit zwei
oder dreitausend menschen aufzunehmen
das wird nicht reichen brauchen eine
andere solidarität es sind allein in
polen in drei wochen knapp zwei
millionen menschen angekommen
polen leistet großartiges ich habe heute
mit einer polnischen delegation sprechen
können aber polen wird nicht mehr viele
menschen aufnehmen können
wenn gute ideen vertreibungs terror so
weiter fortsetzt dann werden in den
nächsten drei wochen wieder zwei bis
drei millionen menschen in die
europäische union kommen
und viele werden alleine von der
geografischen lage dann natürlich
deutschland ansteuern es gibt ja den
wunsch möglichst nah an der heimat zu
bleiben weil auch das ist ein
unterschied zumindest zu teilen
derjenigen von die
2015/2016 gekommen sind dass es einen
unmittelbaren wunsch gibt so schnell wie
möglich wieder zurückzukehren
aber es wird jetzt eben um die
notsituation gehen wie bekommen wir
diese menschen jetzt untergebracht
und wenn wir den gerecht werden wollen
mit den standards wie das eben hier
angemahnt worden ist dann wird es nur
gehen wenn wir die internationale
verteilung hinbekommen wir werden es so
das muss man dann auch sagen wir sagen
immer gerne wir schaffen das und wir
wollen das schaffen und ich bin auch
überzeugt wir werden das schaffen aber
wir werden es eben nur schaffen wenn es
auch diese internationale und
europäische solidarität gibt wenn
beispielsweise die vereinigten staaten
wenn kanada wenn auch australien aber
auch die anderen europäischen länder
wirklich große kontingente auch
übernehmen sonst können wir den schutz
auf dem niveau wie ihr hier
beispielsweise von der kollegin lindholz
vorhin gefordert worden ist gar nicht
leisten
aber ich will das auch dazu sagen
ich gehe davon aus dass es gelingen wird
diese internationale solidarität auch zu
organisieren aber dennoch werden alleine
auch die zahlen die menschen die wir
hier in deutschland bei uns aufnehmen
eine historische herausforderung
es gibt auch einen unterschied zur
polnischen gesellschaft was die aufnahme
angeht wir loben dass jetzt alle dass
das so fantastisch funktioniert hat in
polen zusagen verlassen im bundestag an
dieser stelle um